and when I say that Mexico will pay for
the wall
I've Donald Trump on stage and Amsterdam
not quite well greetings my name is
Gregory Shapiro
otherwise known as the fake Trump
totally terrific mr. president the fake
Trump and his voice went viral most
recently with this video from a Dutch
satire show gonna be absolutely
fantastic we speak Dutch it's the best
language in Europe a hit on stage to
Greg Shapiro is having the time of his
life since Donald Trump took office his
show angry white men is currently
running in Amsterdam in improvisation we
say or in comedy you know sometimes you
improvise a scene and then aliens come
in or whatever then it goes to crazy
town and you don't want to go to you
don't want to get to crazy town too
quickly and Trump just goes straight to
crazy town you know so there's really
not much you need to do Shapiro has been
in the comedy business for over 20 years
first in the US now in Holland since
Trump came along the phone hasn't
stopped ringing interviews TV
appearances his own YouTube show but
it's not only the voice he's had to
perfect his hands they're either making
this one or this one it's like a binary
code it's like Morse code technically
the hands are it's like an SOS distress
call someone please save us that's why
the hands tell the true story I love
immigrants immigrants can come into the
country women I have so much respect so
much respect for women Shapiro calls his
show post-election therapy but is it
really helping
it's still tasteful like I think that
it's appropriate to laugh at things that
you're afraid of and that not laughing
at them is what creates more fear itself
so being able to come here and laugh
about Trump is way better than sitting
at home and being afraid of him I always
lived by you got a laugh or cry I think
this is right way of going about it
but yeah back to the map yeah nervous
laughter because it's like something so
funny but them like it's serious this is
serious despite his own ambivalence
towards Trump Greg Shapiro wants to ride
the wave as long as he can and if the
new president carries on like this
comedians like Shapiro won't ever have
to worry about coming up with fresh
material
[Applause]
you